- Yes, but you've got
two hit "Frozen" movies.
Will there be a third one, more than that?
I love this franchise. (laughs)
- Listen, even though--
- This is my "Star Wars".
- Even though I have zero authority
and no control, I would
like to formally announce
"Frozen" 3, 4, and 5,
(Kelly laughs)
and I just want Disney
to hear that,
(audience laughs and claps)
that I'll be showing up,
and I'll be in my groove,
(audience cheers)
- Regardless!
- Regardless of whether, so
let's do it, let's do it.
- I have no power,
- I have--
- But "Yes, it's happening."
- No control,
but I would like to
formally announce it, yeah.
- (chuckles) All right, you
know what y'all should do, too?
They always do this
sometimes at Hollywood Bowl,
I feel like, where you don't even have to,
they stand behind mics
and everyone's acting out the characters--
- Yeah.
- You should do that.
- We have talked about this because,
between the music from the first one
and the second one that
we all know and love,
and there's a couple
songs that had been cut
that no one's ever heard
from the first one
- Ooh!
- And the second one, we've
been talking about maybe doing
a Hollywood Bowl, maybe televising it,
perhaps next year, with all of our--
- And perhaps,
- With Josh, and Jonathan,
and Idina--
- An invite is fine,
if you wanna
invite me to attend
- Okay, got it, got it,
got it, got it, yes.
- I can help.
I can wear all black and work the stage.
- Amazing.
- I really
just wanna be there.
- (laughs) Okay.
- I love when they do that,
'cause everybody loves
the music, it's a big part of it.